the debate over masks and the corona
virus is entering a
new phase multiple states have recently
dropped their mask mandates
against the advice of the cdc our lead
national correspondent is in new orleans
and he recently visited his hometown
of lafayette louisiana that's david
begno and david
this is a policy issue but it's also
playing out actually between neighbors
isn't it
it is anthony look lafayette's got great
food great people and there is still a
great debate over masks
louisiana has a mask mandate the
governor imposed it and one of the
things it doesn't allow is for large
crowds of people in bars
but take a look at what we saw in
downtown lafayette over the weekend
young people mask-less crowding in bars
some even lining up to get in the back
door
look we are a year into the pandemic and
the city council and lafayette just met
in
emergency session last week to talk
about a mass mandate
and it failed welcome to the heart of
cajun country when it comes to wearing a
mask
public safety is run into politics in
this reliably republican part of the
country
we're not exhibiting the behavior that
the the medical experts
are begging us to do this particular
community has prided
itself on being so loving but in these
dire times
i'm not seeing it at all it really
breaks my heart david
that is peter garisco his 73 year old
father david
died last month due to covet 19
complications
gail george is david's widow i think
perhaps he got it from me
because i was diagnosed three days
before he was
david's death made local news after what
happened to the family at the funeral
home
the headline read family says they were
mocked police called
after requesting mass usage at funeral
home
you think i'm going to let my family
risk their lives because your little
lacks on your
your policy there were people up and
down the hallway
without masks on and we just simply said
listen just please wear a mask
and no one would garisco says the
funeral home did have signs telling
people that masks were required
but they didn't enforce it i found out
that there was no local enforcement
of the state mass mandate what happened
at the funeral home led to community
outrage
and a public memorial honoring grisco
and the more than 200 people who have
died due to covet
in lafayette and last week it also led
to an emergency meeting of the city
council
to consider a local mask mandate mask
have
become political here local doctor
brittany a bear
a yale educated physician who spent more
than three weeks
volunteering on the front lines in new
york city told her city council
a local mouse ordinance will save lives
and if you are strong enough to vote for
it
you will save lives but even before the
vote the city's mayor indicated he would
not enforce
a statewide mandate the council then
voted and the ordinance
failed write down party lines two
democrats voted yes
three republicans all said the mass
mandate was pointless in part
because it wouldn't be enforced and one
of them even raised doubts about the
effectiveness of masks
in an email exchange with none other
than the grisco
family who called the rejection of the
mandate a complete
farce it's all pathetic and laughable
i don't feel safe you don't feel safe in
your own town yeah
yeah here in the state of louisiana
there have been
3 700 mass complaints people saying
folks are not wearing masks do you know
how many
actions the state fire marshal's office
has taken because of that
zero let me say that again zero
enforcement taken
we were told they'd rather educate than
punish
let's make it clear masks work every
infectious disease doctor will tell you
that
masks work period
i don't know how many times you have to
say that david but apparently you need
to keep saying it we all need to keep
saying it people need to hear it
thank you very much